the food industry is more competitive
than it's been in a really long time and
that's because consumers are demanding
more out of grocers out of brand
founders and out of the traditional food
companies but frozen is no different and
it's actually one of the most exciting
categories in the industry today growing
a lot and in fact the the global
industry is expected to reach 290
billion dollars by 2021 daily harvest
was founded at a time when there was a
lot of big raising happening and
direct-to-consumer and a lot of tech
coming into the food world blue apron
was just getting started and getting a 2
billion dollar valuation I've covered
food for a while and had always known
about daily harvest but had never really
met Rachel Rory Rachel took a different
approach to business and at a time when
people were really pushing for more and
customer acquisition and bigger raises
she was focused on capital efficiency
I mean 125 million in sales for 2019
this stage in the game for daily harvest
and being on the way to study state
profitability is a really impressive
business the idea for daily harvest
really started when I was working at
gilt groupe I was finding myself in
back-to-back meetings all day long and
day after day was 3 o'clock and I was no
longer able to make good decisions
I was hangry so I would go into the
kitchen I would go into the pantry and I
would grab something like trail mix or
day old stale birthday cake I knew
better but I just didn't have the time
to eat that way and it was really
crushing me
so daily harvests essentially make
smoothies it makes harvest bowls it
makes oats
it makes chia parfaits daily harvest
works with 400 partner farmers around
the country they're all either organic
or using regenerative agriculture
practices
the reason daily harvest working with
400 farmers is so important is because
the produce that we're usually eating
has been picked months before it's ripe
and well the time it gets to the shelves
that we're buying it from it's been in
warehouses and artificially gassed
typically to ripen and then transport it
around the country but because daily
harvest works with these farmers and
freezes directly on-site they're able to
have produce actually be ripened fully
on the vine or the tree they're able to
keep it
frozen at peak ripeness peak nutritional
value and that's what gets circulation
up to you the reason I started with
smoothies is because it was something
that I knew people would understand and
I knew it was something that was that
was pretty habitual and you know the
vision was always like how do we turn
the freezer in every single kitchen into
a self replenishing personalized pantry
of good clean food that's ready in
seconds
daily harvest bestseller right now is
around ninety dollars a week for twelve
cups that's around seven dollars per cup
but that's not really that cheap for
something that's the size they are in
the process of changing their sizing the
harvest bowls will be bigger the
breakfast parfaits and
chia pudding z' will be smaller and it
all kind of comes out in the wash there
are a lot of women in the food brand
space but there are very few in the food
tech area and rachel is a pioneer in
that way she has been pregnant twice
through building this company and then
she raised her series a well she was
pregnant and having to raise
considerable VC money you know several
months pregnant is is not an easy feat
it's not something that I think people
take lightly and it's something that
takes a lot of courage so during my seed
round somebody actually asked me how I
plan to grow a big business and be a
good mother and you know I couldn't
justify that question so so what I was
responded was you know if what you're
asking is if I'm a hundred percent
dedicated to building this business my
answer is yes so does daily harvest have
staying power I think there's a place
for it people are looking for are
convenient healthy foods more than ever
and daily harvest has figured out an
entirely new supply chain and I think as
long as there are transparent ingredient
lists it will continue to be successful
you